[Music]
i won't ever waste my time
[Music]
how's the trip going
it's awesome yeah so where are you
i'm in los angeles uh hustling
uh taking care of a couple fires i'm so
sorry i can't be with everybody
why are you guys there because one of
you may taste the candy that you've
never had before and become infatuated
with it bring me back one i taste it
and seven years later we buy the company
right like
[ __ ] like that and so and
then obviously number three uh one of
the things that i want to continue to
build on is
eq and team building like you can't
imagine
what's running through my head right now
on on this short little trip
on how you guys are gonna build some i
mean a lot of you guys don't know each
other
and and you're gonna go from not knowing
each other or even saying hello in the
hall
to having inside jokes having a
friendship and maybe even a really great
friendship and i do think that that's
something that i aspire to for our
organization
uh it's just a fun trip i mean there's a
fun trip aspect i also think that your
thinking is extremely valuable and
you're going to be able to give some of
that
to the people you cross paths with over
the next 72 hours as well so
just a lot of good good good good good
that adds up to an exciting trip and
obviously
disappointed that i i had to deal with a
fire that didn't allow me to come
this is a final boarding call for the
airport
[Music]
my name is andy cranach i'm brand
director for garyvee at vaynermedia
hi my name is lexie finger i am a media
manager on the paid media team at
vaynermedia
hey i'm lisa vinicott i'm a senior media
planner on chase hi
i'm vinnie i'm an acv associate creative
director at vaynermedia on the
entertainment team
hi my name is jody schwartz i am
director
of experience strategy and design at
vader media
my name is martha and i'm a senior art
director in the
la office my name is christina
blankenship i
am a media supervisor on the paid team
i'm helena i'm an art director
my name is james davey i am an account
executive
working out of vaynermedia london i
think i got nominated to go on this trip
because i got the best squad and they
just wanted to give me love and send me
to helsinki i think i got nominated for
this trip
because i love winter in the snow and
i've made that very clear to all my
co-workers
my director actually wasn't able to come
to this trip so i subbed in and was
asked to come
three days before we flew uh i think i'm
known a little bit to be a bit of a
straight shooter and kind of get to the
root
of why things are the way they are i am
happy to be
here in helsinki because i was able to
be a representative of
vaynermedia for some potential clients i
think i got nominated
because i have wonderful co-workers that
love me
i kind of abuse the vacation policy of
unlimited vacation
in turn i am just like always online
whenever
i actually do go on vacation so i think
my team just wanted me to unplug
for a while i think i got nominated to
come to helsinki because i can speak to
a lot of aspects of production
maybe i'm just good at cracking on
getting the job done and trying to
exhibit
the key veiner values uh that pretty
much i see
being exhibited every day around me
started already 2001 but we actually
took some uh careful thinking and some
banging head on the wall and then
finally 2007
it kind of saw the the daylight
beginning it was kind of
really small we had like a tiny cellar
like all the patterns were
hand-drawn on the paper and made all the
samples and
everything was like handmade
[Music]
it's uh 12 p.m helsinki wednesday
whole group has finally arrived right
now we're going to
some top culinary chef to uh comparison
mills and have a culinary lesson
[Music]
it's cold had a great
meal cooked by us the
head culinary chef of finland now we're
going to arctic startup
[Music]
so welcome to old maria hospital this
used to be hospital more than 100 years
and two years ago the city of helsinki
decided to convert into a startup hub
and today
it's home to about 80 startups 15
investment companies and then a couple
of service providers
totally more than 600 people already
operating here
today we're going to hear some pitches
from our
core business related media events and
then we're gonna hear some of these
other portfolio companies
tell us about what they're doing
[Music]
now sing you in the lobby we're just
jamming on the deck's mini 40s
presentation we're going to be doing
we're breaking up into two groups and
going through two different companies
trying to deliver the things that they
asked of us and then also giving them
context on what bmd does
it's exciting it's fun to jam with these
people and learn more about uh
what they do day to day at vayner and
really impress with just their skills
and talents and
different uh expertise we have here so
it's fun
uh somewhere in helsinki through the
snow
over the river and through the woods to
um jan's friend's place we go you don't
know what i'm talking about d
uh we're going to go present to um we're
going to go
present uh the 4ds and what uh vayner
does
um to a bunch of these companies that
youngs put together so we can give them
a little idea of what we do how we do it
um
and giving like a little peek under the
hood of vaynermedia
so i think it should be great we put
some uh great presentations together
hopefully they get a little something
out of it
beautiful snow here in helsinki just
took a trip
wrap it up that's how you say it
yeah candy chocolate
[Music]
so we wrapped up with foxer we had some
candy chocolate
good lunch now is heading back to the
city center
going to the shortcut community they
help
refugees and immigrants to integrate
into the finnish ecosystem
via business
[Music]
we are at that long week i've never
actually been here before but it's like
this very nice conference center
i've been laying changing too long i've
been way too in my zone
i'm just so caught up in money baby i
ain't even chasing them hoes
but what i want you to do now you see
these cars beautiful different cars this
from game called
dixit so what we have a plant right now
is that you pick
two cards one that represents you
and your inner self and two that
represents
what you're willing to give to the group
today whether that's skills or whether
that's
who you are whatever anything what do
you want to give
to the group
[Music]
i love being like vulnerable and not
knowing what's going on but also just
like winging it
you know looking for good incentives
today looking for that you know blue sky
thinking
i think i'm like kind of shy and quiet
at the start but like some of you have
learned that i'm like really kind of
just crazy
a synonym for um design is manipulation
the artist manipulated the art so their
designer
and that's also me
[Music]
and my favorite part of this trip to
helsinki has been
connecting with the eight of the people
that i was flown here with
making 10 new best friends all the
friends that i've made here
even though we've been in the same
building how hard we've been going
it's been outrageous how much we've been
working and playing
and we've worked with so many different
companies and startups
yan has really and everyone at arctic
startup has really
redefined my mindset and my definition
of hustling
when we get into a room and start
working together and putting together
some thought starters there's like that
one common thread that comes through
like we're across departments but we all
have that same approach to work same
tactics
the sauna i thought it's the i think
it's a
great experience and i like the
combination of
cold and warm walking barefoot in the
ice and snow
because it gave me perspective about
what real cold is
i will never complain again the
hospitality of
all the people here that we've met in
finland uh all the people who have
helped organize this
any kind of interaction we've had with
the people here
has been phenomenal when we were putting
together what we were going to talk
about
through these presentations i noticed
that myself and the other people on the
team even though we worked in different
different departments in different
disciplines we still had a lot of the
same
core tenants that we were going to be
speaking to and then personally
i would say i mean i'm sure everybody
gives the same answer but the but the
people we had a lot of great
just moments and i got to know a lot of
really cool people on the team that i
hadn't worked with
closely before or the couple people i
didn't know i got to know them better
so between the dance parties that we had
and the time
joking around on the bus or the
different vans we took
and you know even ice skating that we
did this afternoon
i got to know a bunch of people uh just
in a different way than you do in the
office and i think
that that core togetherness is what
makes it so strong
so thanks claude thanks gary thanks to
whoever nominated me for this
very much appreciated and hopefully i
can return that favor sometime
you